don't even guys before the video starts
miss do check it out it's a brilliant up
for those who want to pray Salah and
share the rewards check them out now you
know and she look she did not expect us
to realize that you're doing the same
symbol in the club yes well and then
you're doing it again yes yeah well
you're pretending to be so so I'm
worried you can what happened Toria
better care to bothers and sisters and
dear friends welcome to this video and
in this video I will be also we came
across a disturbing video which we saw
and we noticed something within this
video I don't know if you guys have seen
it but this is hasanat doing rupiah on a
system a sister now since a lot of
things have been going on the assumption
of assuming the best me as well a lot of
people save over Ali you know you too so
I've always assumed the best I'm telling
you as a Adama assume the best is gone
out the window
there is no assume the best yeah with
people who have crossed limits or all
angles I'll be an absolute idiot to
assume the best I'm sorry so therefore
I'm going to make some insurer a case
for it now we're gonna watch your video
together you guys are gonna watch it and
I want you guys to listen very carefully
I want you to look at two things the
hand motion of the one who's possessed
and two hasanat voice listen very very
carefully have you heard enough
leaving the obedience of Allah why why
won't you leave and what's your mission
you know very well how wrong this is
and that Allah will hold you to account
for it this is your last chance to leave
listen very carefully you know very well
how wrong this is
and that Allah will hold you to account
for it like real they put up as a real
thing I don't know if this is real this
is fake if they made it public or
making public what is wholesome is very
simple you are mocking the Dean because
number one missing book she does this
with a handsy and yes see you sanic is
now a she's on the club's exactly that's
what I'm seeing in in in a video where
that I was assumed in the best where she
came as says she's living a double life
so forget to swim in the best and I'm
gonna talk about nother aspect as well
she does that she takes a picture like
this same thing I noticed him now he are
husana is this okey this is this thing
yeah you must think she's actually
involved there's two possibilities you
might don't kill anyone says oh I don't
know I have no doubt me personally I
can't stomach to bring it
this is boom Abdullah is one of his
wives I believe this with my been
walking the look like he's he's mocking
oh Allah will do this to you he's
mocking and you know what's disturbing
okay listen listen to this here we're
gonna come before I start torturing you
again this is your last chance to leave
filthy hubby
maybe this will change your mind shivers
you know I get shivers for you know what
Allah says in the whole internal
[ __ ] but you would look at this
speech okay forget speech the way
recites the Koran okay I get shivers for
two reason number one is the - Kalam of
Allah number two how he is mocking and
recite the Quran I'm sorry that you can
mock the Deen of Allah and then recite
the Quran with power
okay how does one do it now the issue is
forget hasanat it for a second because
we've been talking too much about Hannah
yeah I want to make something clear key
every time this happens be in marital
issues whatever issues are key a sister
comes cries a few tears her sister and
what my wish upon Allah say call it the
chivalry effect
I don't you call the chivalry whatever
every you call it yeah okay with this
enough as OMA just because a female
comes in has tears does not mean that
all of a sudden no
observe just because a man doesn't cry
or even if you cry some call him a wimp
or whatever I'll show you get ours no we
will not fall for this
oh ma boola Sarah whoever it may be who
else is involved you are as much to
blame now is mutually consented yes now
the reason why we didn't talk about
Abdullah specifically is for reasons we
know which are confidential but their
surface we cannot tell you and please
for those instead of assuming the worst
we are believers well not when I [ __ ]
ya to assume the worst in us what we're
saying is this things we can't tell you
okay so if we didn't do what we did with
Pam I know there wouldn't be no
evidences nothing would have happened
would happen everything would have been
brushed under the carpet there's no
evidence it's not true so please know
that we know what we was doing we didn't
go and wait six seven hours in a room
for no reason yeah okay you know so no
crocodile tears you are as much to blame
the only difference is this the only
difference we're in an Islamic angle
where we was hard on has an ad and not
these two as much it's because the
evidence that was brought forth to us
saw some stuff for life we saw some
stuff where we said there's a
possibility they're victims but they
were still they were still there's
things that they did there so we want to
make it very clear exactly we come with
evidence we can't just oh let's just
pick on them for sake of it no the
evidence suggested that this guy was for
Syria was of disbelief there was
clear-cut evidences now there was some
disgusting filthy things that were done
as a group I'm not gonna go into detail
I don't want you I don't care
privates you stay private yeah but all
we know is that they yes yes but issues
that pertain to the Ummah and the
general public
yes we bring it online so no crocodile
tears would make us so we just wanna
make that very clear but this was very
disturbing
that's why I care if there's anything
you want this whole thing move he's
doing a devil symbol yeah you know and
she look she did not expect us to
realize that you're doing the same
symbol in the club yes
well and then you're doing it again yes
yeah when you're pretending to be so
what is that so I will I you know what
you could be working with the shell team
you could be either your internship with
machete or number two should I tell you
something here you
what you was mocking you was with you no
no the mockingly being on the same Koran
that before they were either you did it
intentionally to do to you if you don't
disbelieve at that moment of time your
finger okay this is all joke so when you
went to the rakia these jeans that we
believe in may be really possessed you
yeah and you got possessed because you
was thinking that this is not real and
it was real you got possessed and you're
doing okay that man look at this recital
not good ad and mocking the Deen of
Allah well I have never seen any
anything so a Jeep in my life is
anything to another lucky yeah last
thing I want to say is that you know
you've been found out you've been
ameliorated and there's gonna be more
and more of you that are gonna be weeded
out of our cool the money is next where
did the money call we need to know with
the money where the money went where the
money went show us something was
seriously well I show us something where
the money went
but you know what we just been having a
conversation with someone today and we
kind of made estimations as to how much
these were coming up coming up in Congo
and the money let's say it's anything
between 200 to 300 thousand pounds a
year can you imagine now as another
question are you paying taxes or that
way
what has been changing is company that's
what I want to find out because that's
something which is actually concerns
Inland Revenue yes yes so if we
understand yeah no Muslim communities
understand these these particular
individuals peace process yes two
hundred thousand pounds yeah three
hundred thousand pounds four hundred
thousand five five hundred thousand
pounds well so are you filing that they
were having minimum free to four
customers
no problem a minimum minimum five
hundred plus 500 pounds a day times my
365 that's 180 thousand five hundred
ninety thousand yeah let's see let's
give them a couple of days off let's say
two days or whatever it may be it will
still be at least 130 thousand just two
hundred fifty thousand that's the
minimums we're talking about well I know
this guy be making four hundred pounds
per okay service anyway anyways that's
it inshallah you know what I might even
right now we don't know I might even
plug in the video off testimony from the
brother who worked with them if all of
this is true then know that that's not
you are a fee
you are a liar you're a vile human being
you're a selfish crooked crooked an evil
man and you have used me of my time
you have tricked me you have conned me
into believing that you are a Muslim you
have conned the public I've always just
wanted to do good and help people and
you've put my name into your dirt and
you've put my name into your dirt and
all I want to do all I've wanted to do
is help people and the only way you can
galv this is by yourself on your luck
and reveal the full truth but you can
only clarify this and I have nothing to
do of you nothing nothing in I will
never forgive you this guy who worked
with them testify into this not it's not
even on Instagram each other may Allah
bless you guys for watching make sure
that you go to the instagrams yes we put
a lot of the evidences on the grounds on
Twitter so check that exact and no need
that Bowman sisters this attack on our
religion you know what this shows it
makes a stronger one like it just makes
a stronger we will come for you guys and
we were gonna come for you guys
inshallah